foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
spatially resolved transcriptional atlas
of the Miriam dorsal pontine tegmentum
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by vizgen
to learn more visit thisgen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers Dr
Stefano nardone research scientists
Harvard Medical School and death Israel
Deaconess Medical Center For Life
Sciences
and Corey Branigan Solutions engineer at
heavy AI
Stefano Corey you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the kind introduction and
today I'm going to describe a project
that is you know ongoing in
a red lower lab
we are characterizing both specially and
transcriptionally the more Universal
point integumentum before starting
I would like to give an overview where
is the dorsal point integumentum and
which kind of religion it is
part of the ponds and uh the pawns is a
major division
of the brain stem
uh as you can see the bounce uh is
divided into part A basilar ponds that
is more ventral and the dorsal part that
is the point integumentum
and it span from minus 4.9 millimeters
from bregma to minus 5.8 and uh with
special task atomics particularly
employing Memphis we characterize this
region
doing a section every 10 microns uh from
minus 4.9 to minus 4.8 across so from
Russia we have all sequential section in
four mice
so just to to give an over glue
um of the project flowchart
we have a phase one in which we
characterize transcriptional in this
region and we apply drunk SEC that is a
single nuclei rnsic technology droplet
bista more or less like 10x and
um after uh we clustered the cell and
the final the cell type each cell types
defined by differential expression of
assigning a marker that is a unique Gene
that is expressed by that specific
population and then we use this Mass
cell type space
in phase three then after we partner
with the vi when we
with the special viewer to visualize and
query the data set in real time instead
of using static plot
the the section strategy we use for
drone SEC was very diverse and um
it's basically a point on two different
regions
one is the lateral parabolical nucleus
that you can see in red
and another one is the Barrington
nucleus that you can see in green
the two strategy were different because
the Barrington nucleus as a theory as a
high salary transpiration so we use a
reporter mice for gfp and so we were
able to pinpoint this region and as you
can see in the bottom on the right we we
were able to micro dissect angle the
fluorescent microscope for the pbn
strategy
uh we use the A40 mice that basically
has like a stop cassette
um that flanked by two Lock speed sites
and the only one you inject and
adenovirus that is Cree in the NTS
basically it happens the recombination
and the determinator that is the protein
fluorescent you can see is expressed
fibers from the ntsd projectively to the
lateral parallel allowing us to the
sector and to have a guide during the
dissection
so after uh with the drunk cycle we
clustered all ourselves as you can see
here in the Disney figure scheme uh we
were able to characterize them neurons
foreign
type 1 and type 2. the microglia and
perivascular macrophages epidemicide
and so on and uh of Interest neurons
accounted for 60 percent of the entire
population that we provide around 150
000 nuclei that pass the quality control
Next Step was to
doing the neuronal clustering of the
roots at ntg we were
we are interested in the in the neurons
so we separate only the neurons we
isolate the neurons from the uh from the
glia
and the non-neuronal cells and we divide
them in excitatory and inhibitory the
excited
basically the express bigot one two and
three
and plus we included in that also uh
chat neurons cholinergic
serotoninergic neurons and neural energy
neurons while in the inhibitory neurons
we have like bigot and as marker but
also they espresso some transporter for
the glycine so some of them are also
glycinergic and we have a few clusters
of hybrid neurons that means these
neurons the Espress both
electrophysiologically speaking we don't
know which is
on the bottom you can see on the y-axis
the genes while on this axis the cluster
so we identify the total of 33 and 29
clusters both were excitatory and
inhibitory neurons
however the brain
and single cell technology is a very
powerful technology to characterize the
transcriptome of the brain by doesn't
Supply uh what is like a special
resolution so we we have like a sort of
uh information from each population but
we don't know where it's located and
here comes the special caspitomics and
particularly
May fish we partnered with the Beach gen
and we apply Memphis to this region the
most important things to understand is
that we choose the highly variable genes
it means genes that are markers that are
expressed only in certain specific
population and then we use a panel of
315 genes
to locate these populations
here you can see a message to sugar
thing officer of 10 sequential section
from rostral to gaudal
after we cut this uh 10 Micron and fix
it section
we'll go through all lab a process
that's been done by which gen in their
lab which there is like fixation a
premization cell boundary staining
abilization and gel embedding and
digestion and cleaning after the Sun the
out the output
is basically
a list of detected transcripts
most like images in Thief in which you
can see that
uh tusky personal Medics and metadata
and cell boundaries so these are the
cell boundaries so-called segmentation
and we Define
um the cell boundary of the doors in the
bottom right
and and so we'll pull only the cells and
the transcripts inside that region
because we were interested all in that
region and we choose the gene to be
either variable for that specific region
after that we did more or less the same
approach we use for uh
uh single cell sequencing
and we cluster all the cells we are the
only in this region
nearly 700 000 says that pass the
quality controller but on all the slides
we have six million cells in all the 49
slides that we image
um then we divide the neurons in
excitatory and Inhibitors as we did
before
and uh
and and and what and what we did is uh
like finding the unique marker for each
uh cluster as we did also in a single
cell
one of the
uh is your
side of classing or neurons or the big
region is that uh we lose a some
granularity in the clustering so to gain
so to gain more granularity and to build
an address that is of interest of
investigators that they go and they
perform cellodactic injections in
specific regions some regions actually
we then divide the dorsal point
integrine for sub-region that we
anatomically Define it
another another approach we applied is
to perform a canonical correlation
analysis between Murphy dong SEC
clusters in the course in the dorsal
point integumentum this is very
important because when there is a direct
correspondence as in some of the gay
system
you you can infer genes that that you
don't that you didn't uh acid or probed
with my fish from the drunk SEC data set
so we found that 71 out of the 85 meters
identified classes correspond to 49 to
59 Zone second identified cluster in the
mouse dorsal content integument
so as I said we divide this region in
four Atlas the first is the Collegiate
loser second is lateral parability
then we have the Mason cephalic to
General lab the prelocution
and in the fourth address is more the
media region with the lateral Dosa
segmental nucleus the Ventra segmental
nucleus
and so on
today we're gonna talk about the address
2 just to give an example of how we
build the parabriel complex address
complex is formed by local leader fuse
and the parabriel
and is an important relay in this region
for all the input that comes from
for instance stretch or nutrient sensing
from the gut through the vagus nerve the
NTS and then the parabriel or through
the spino parabolic extract the incense
warm cold pain
and then after all also Energy starts
through the arcade then the pdh mc4
receptor through the pbn to an unknown
population
after the bbne project to high order
sites when where they set the emotional
balance to motivate the big
so in this in this slide what we did is
basically defining as we showed before
uh some boundaries on the dappy and then
we
pull only the cell and the transcript
that were in those boundaries
after we clustered all the sales around
80 000 cells
and we plot this boronoi Blood the sort
of cartographic map
all the glasses that are color coded as
you can see on the Disney on the right
we divided the cluster industrial
counter is cutted according to their
frequency
as you can see on the bottom you can see
the frequency of the Clusters and you
have a blackma level on the x-axis and
the second counting percentage on the
y-axis
for instance if you wanted to
um pinpoint where is protodinos things
that are clearly these neurons in Orange
here
but you're not sure whether on the
cartographic map on the Moroni plot you
may see the idea there is a bump it
means there is there are more neurons
here in this part and so it's a 5 minus
5.35 that is this level
the same is for calcaneurons that we
know the well known population in the
rostral parabolican nucleus and then
they go ending toward the governor part
and mostly shifting in the medial part
so this helps a lot to visualize what uh
um our results and to get inside however
this study plot especially for
um population that are very rare and
represent less than one percent maybe of
the data set are not very indicative
here in this other slides we then
characterize the top two markers for
each of the uh
all the Clusters
and then we asked that question
if mice and human neurons subtype very
high degree of transitional conservation
in this area we retrieved from
[Music]
um
selected Ultra linear Sun lab
single cell single nuclear data from
Human from the same region
and as before we clustered them
and as you can see the percentage is 66
percent of the neurons that is very
close to the one we had before uh
pointed out with my fish we plot the
same genes and we divided it excitatory
and inhibitory Define genes that are
marker genes and the number of clusters
for each
um
group
after we asked the same question before
and we calculate the correspondence
between cluster for single nuger and
satu one ptmg
first stronger than a sec in the same
area
and we found that there is a very high
correspondence you may see here for
instance kalka that is one cgrp one of
the main most studied cluster uh
population in the parabolism will
correspond to a calc evolution in the
Mouse
so
we went actually uh back in time and we
we looked at if really is the there is
this kalka uh cgrp and uh neurons in
human and we found the paper which
actually uh they identified these
neurons they are in the same position uh
where we found in the mouse it means in
the external lateral part of the
parabrigan nucleus and so after we
looked at that statistic Channel profile
of the doctor stressed genes and we
found that
that transcriptional provides quite
similar it's not identic
here on the top on the Dot Plot you may
see pbn SNL these are all the
nuclei of the parabolical nucleus in
human except
and these are all the calcasels it means
the calcaglaster number two this one
you can see here
without any other
sales for any other cluster and the same
has been done in drunk well you see Alka
in a mouse here and you can see as the
same pattern of expression and also
Murphy's where there is a white spot is
because the gene was not detected in my
fish because we didn't test it
um for my part I wanted to thank you my
boss Beth Lowell and all the
co-owners of this work
and I will give the floor to Cody
thanks a lot
all right yeah thank you a lot Stefano
um
just for context the final of I and I
have been working together on uh his
work uh within heavy Ai and his research
so I've been supporting that
um
and
um so yeah
before we get into the tool itself I was
just hoping to planning to give a little
bit of an overview of uh what we do here
and uh how we've been helping out um in
with uh Stefano's research
uh so to begin having AI is a technology
that allows organizations and users to
interactively analyze and visualize
their their largest data sets uh so
we're talking about scales of 10 million
to tens of billions record in records uh
delivering in results instantaneously
um so I don't need to tell anyone that
data volumes have exploded at a
remarkable rate
and those volumes are now outpacing
gains in traditional computing power
so having enough data to educate our
decisions is no longer the problem
the problem has shifted to analyzing and
making sense of that data
so heavy AI was founded in 2013 when our
founder Todd mostac was in a graduate
program study actually at Harvard as
well he was looking at the Arab Spring
through the lens of Twitter
um so he quickly felt limited by the
sequel tools that was available to him
he would typically run an analytical
query overnight and either find it still
going in the morning failed or require
some change uh which would start the
process over again
um
so we built a querying engine that was
powered by gpus taking advantage of the
parallel processing they could do
with data in memory
so we have funding from Top tier
eventual Capital firms and of many
customers and partners in the Fortune
500 uh for for example
um we enhanced s p Global's energy
studio for understanding oil and gas
Investments
we helped Charter with offloading mobile
devices to hotspots and other antennas
and we worked with so-called Edison
which is one of the largest Utilities in
the country
uh to mitigate Wildfire risk around
their power lines
so we solved these challenges by
allowing customers to work at scale
we believe that people make the best
Decisions by literally seeing all of
their data together
in one place
even if it comes from multiple sources
and is continuously changing
so like I said extremely large data sets
in the orders of hundreds of millions to
tens of billions of Records
are no stranger to us at all
so we want you to bring your data as it
is that means no down sampling
no pre-aggregation or data reshaping
required
we can import data sets directly into
heavy AI or connect to them currently
where they currently live and the
infrastructure that you've already
invested in
uh we can organize it uh into dashboards
and charts
allowing you to interactively find
hidden opportunities and risks you can
find patterns and anomalies understand
your behavior over time compare
scenarios between different models or
data sets
and identify and measure relationships
between them yeah typical operations you
want your data analysts to be able to
perform
um
the difference here is that these
results are delivered instantaneously
enabled by rethinking the analytics
solution to Leverage The Power of gpus
uh heavy and I enabled heavy AI enables
you to speed up your SQL queries over
100x
and allows you to visually interact with
your data
when you compare versus the cost of
running these jobs in a traditional CPU
based environment uh it's up to 10 times
cheaper and can be 10 to 100 times
faster
so the heavy AI stack includes both an
end user product and a platform
accelerator and we leverage that GPU
power throughout the stack
uh we can connect or import data
directly from data warehouses data Lakes
S3 parquet files and through standard
odbc connections
you can use the full stack or utilize
different parts to power third-party
applications such as interfacing with
machine word learning workflows
accelerating other bi tools or building
custom rendering applications
so we have four basic components
first we have heavy DB and that's our
SQL engine that's tailor-made for gpus
that powers heavy render our rendering
engine for delivering visuals of large
amounts of data
and on top are interactive no code
visual environment heavy immersed so
this is a dashboard building environment
that allows engagement by more
non-technical users
and can be shared out more broadly
and we also have heavy connect and
that's our this is our foreign storage
interface and that allows you to connect
to a data source and leave it where it
is it reads the data directly into the
GPU memory cache
uh so just for reference here's a number
of customers whose decisions we are
supporting today long with a handful of
Technology partners that we work with uh
yeah as you can see a lot of large
Enterprises
um and also plenty of work on the
intelligence and and federal side
um trust us with their data with doing
um very critical analysis
so getting into the interface itself uh
here's just a quick preview of what uh
Stefano will show
uh while the main chart on the left hand
side is typically used for geospatial
data anything that uses Point
coordinates are supported and so as you
can see when when zooming in
we have both points and polygons in this
View
and so now I'll hand it off to Stefano
to show how this works interactively
thank you Cody
so let me share the screen
uh
some server
so I guess everyone can see now the
dashboard so this is an interactive
dashboard that we designed with a heavy
eye and that is holding inside the data
that we just talked in the presentation
as you can see we plotted the
segmentation just for our Dosa quantity
segmentum and also the statistics uh
cell cell by cigarette clusters I mean
the cellular statistics are and regards
only the door serpent integment however
we plotted all the transcript
and in the future we will plot even all
the segmentation
and on we were able to see
um for instance like in our those cell
content integumentary documentation
around 13 000 cells only on this slide
and
on the overall section
we have we have a thought a lot more
than uh
65 million uh spots so let's navigate
inside to see how does it work as you
can see it's all interactive I mean the
statistic change when you zoom in on
zoom out
and uh why not do it you may at a
certain level of Zoom you may start
seeing actually the cellular structure
so
it works basically
that is possible to select
structure
from here
for instance we wanted to know
all listed this population
and we can get rid of all the genes for
instance
so this is the dosa
and here there is the prediction in
wrong it means that basically in between
the two technologies there is agreement
on uh that in the the the same cluster
in merfish has been characterized by
drunk so basically if we didn't
characterize any Gene in my fish we can
go back to drunk and to single nuclear
and a second means and uh check that
Gene because we know that there is a
correspondence done by CCA by from the
two populations
so you here you can see uh both uh the
doors that is marked by tph2 and it's
transporter
or serotonin
and uh and and for instance you can you
can see also some other
uh population this this should be the
dtn
you can you may see the event adding
democrite but I know what if we want to
overlap
um the gene on this
so we can go in custom selection
and we can select for instance some
other Genie we wanted to see uh just so
I remember some marker of the
in democide
and you will have your Market plotted
here now you cannot see them because it
is covered
you see how this uh population is
basically highly enriched for these two
markers
of course then you can have a broader
View of the neuronal organization just
plotting
all the cells
in this region and uh mostly actually
taking out the genes
so as you can see here each cluster is
uh is on special pattern
and correspond basically to this is the
vtn and correspond to specific region so
there is like a special organization in
this region so
if we want to go
um and look and
uh one of the four Atlas we did
we take a look at the parabolical
nucleus
foreign
part of the barability precise is -5
.35 from Break map
and that's before we can take out the
genes
in in Gray you can see download cells of
the glia
we were a little bit abundant with the
boundaries but one of the interesting
things is this function of lasso that we
have because if you are interested for
instance in this cluster here in the
Disneyland but you don't know where it's
located you can do
mostly a
lasso on the
my mistake
you can do a last on the
PCV cluster
and you will see only this class
uh and this can be done for many other
clusters but mostly important you can
see that there is also here in
organization of all these clusters
some are like more dorsal some other are
more lateral and then cluster is
characterized by a specific marker
okay
so if if you want to change slice we are
interested in uh
going for distance to another Atlas
this is possible
and you just need to change here the
um the address name
press the address for for instance
now all the classes are in the
statistical refers to this more medial
part of the brain
in which we actually can see a very nice
organization of the dorsal segment and
English
and here
this is The Adventurous Technologies and
this is the dorsal
and also here you may see a very
particular using a special organization
so
um after this I mean we can start taking
some questions
um
I will start sharing the
viewer
all right well thank you Stefano and
Corey for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
asks were there other AI applications
you considered before selecting heavy AI
okay so this is a question for me I
guess so basically yes we found we tried
um
other applications
but actually uh with the FBI we found
that the rendering and actually the
speed
um and the number of uh data that we can
plot are far higher than uh other
company so this is why we partner with
them to create because data in the
future is just uh uh supposed to grow
and so uh even if uh their capability
now exceed what are our data that we are
inputting in the uh in their dashboard
in the future we will have a billion of
data uh that need to be visualized and
uh and so I think Avi is a very strong
partner for this
all right thank you
next question here is a two-part
question and this asks how many genes
were in The Murphys panel and did you
get help selecting the panel
yeah sure
um in the mattress panel there are 315
genes
uh we uh as I said we selected the genes
the hybrid variable genes it means genes
that have a high variability among all
the cells and these usually are those
that by differential expression then we
identify as markers means the genes that
are expressed only in a specific cell
population that is neurons
um and uh yes we we did get help from
its Journey selecting uh the panel and
especially because we matched our uh
Gene with the most expressed ISO form in
the brain
and so because we do this we are sure uh
to
to have a like a reliable results
because some genes have different
typesoform some isophone may be known as
pressed in the brain and so this is why
we have like
um an RNA SEC data set that allows us to
understand which are which is the
highest isoform for each gene we wanted
to select
great
next question here asks besides data
analysis and visualization of murphish
data do you see other uses for AI in
biological research
Corey do you want to to try to answer
this
uh if you want to take it I'm not the uh
experts
so yes there are rather use either using
for artificial intelligence in uh
in uh
for instance like uh in drug Discovery
uh or
um in pathology there is like a lot of
application for artificial intelligence
yes for sure
great
next question we have another two-part
question here is this running on a
desktop and how is the software deployed
uh yeah that one I can take uh so this
is
uh software is deployed on premises
um
and so generally that'll be on a local
server or you can use you know any any
of the different Cloud providers and
spin up a machine on there
so it'll require
uh just anything with a Nvidia GPU
that's just respect to the amount of
data that you'll be working with
um
and uh so yeah everything can live
within your cloud or within um your
on-site Hardware so uh no
no worries around data security there
great thank you
and another question for you Corey what
preparation was done for the data that
is being displayed before importing into
the platform
uh so very little uh we received this
data from Biz gen and
uh
I think so just some of the a couple
adjustments that were made were just
around the point data of just a kind of
scaling the values a little bit so they
were more manageable to work with on um
on our mapping chart and
um
other than that we were able to
just import directly into heavy Ai and
immediately do uh perform the visuals
from there
awesome
all right well we are going to go ahead
and wrap up there so I want to thank you
again Stefano and Corey for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor viz Jen for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and are
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information you had
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event so until next time
take care everyone goodbye